the seven heroines i mean eight many
fans of breath of the wild remember the
famous giant statues located in the
eastern gerudo area
some because of their experience with
them in game and others because the
statues have been the subject of
many popular zelda theories in the past
four years i mean after all
they are pretty mysterious finding these
giant ladies out in the desert is
similar to finding the pyramids of egypt
in real life
both are monumental intricately crafted
seemingly impossible pieces of art
and yet somehow the ancient
civilizations of the past were able to
construct them but one of the most
mysterious details about these large
ladies is the number of them
you see there are seven with one removed
making eight in total
normally the assumption amongst the
fanbase is that the seven statues
represent the seven sages from ocarina
of time since they seemingly represent
people by looking like
you know people and that's really the
only time the number seven appears in
the entire franchise
however this still doesn't explain the
purpose or identity of the eighth
since really there are eight statues and
not truly just
seven their ancient excavation site even
proves this
and let's just be honest here being
specific about numbers is
very important to understanding zelda
lore after all it's not like there are
four pieces of the triforce right
anyway i wanted to present to you today
another possible explanation for not
only the number of giant women statues
including the eighth but also the
strange symbols that these statues are
adorned with
and since the subject is pretty big i
have been joined by none other than the
absolute legend conrad from the
commonwealth realm we just
finished talking about the possible
gerudo and zonai connection
yeah i'm here to talk about the
possibility of the heroine statues being
something completely different than we
thought
alright let's do this thing as bandit
previously mentioned numbers
are one of the most vital details in
zelda lore you have the three pieces of
the triforce
four giants in majora's mask five adult
dungeons in ocarina of time
six elements of the universe and seven
total sages including the leader
zelda herself these numbers are all
specific and not debatable when birth
the wild first released
fans were amazed at the sheer amount of
shoutouts and easter eggs placed around
the world of hyrule that were all
somehow referencing the games of the
past stumbling across these seven heroin
statues in the desert
led the vast majority of fans to come to
the conclusion that the number was meant
to represent the sages from ocarina of
time
since that's the only other time the
number 7 appears in zelda law
however there are some issues with this
assumption that i would like to point
out firstly and most obviously there are
actually 8 of them even though the
heroin
shrine that appears when you match their
symbols with their corresponding orbs
only needs seven orbs to be matched
implying initially that the eight might
not matter the fact instead is that
there are quests associated with the
eight
and there is indeed an eight giant
heroin statue on the far
side of mount the gods which is simply
too large of a detail to
ignore secondly if the seven sages are
to be represented by seven heroines
that must mean that one of them has to
represent the leader
princess zelda herself as she is the
only reason there are seven
sages in the first place however none of
these statues feature any unique
characteristics that might
serve to distinguish the leader from the
others except for this one which sword
has broken but that's probably nothing
you would think that the actual tangible
physical incarnation of goddess hylia
who also happens to be the princess of
legend as well as leader of the sages
would merit some sort of distinction
amongst the group
lastly the heroines are located in the
gerudo desert
this might be a small detail but if you
think about it that is a strange
location to represent the sages of
hyrule
the masters or chamber in the wind waker
is the only area in the game
paying tribute to the sages from ocarina
of time and it's located in hyrule
castle
the home of the hylian royal family who
protect the triforce which is what this
entire franchise is really about
placing a tribute to the seven sages who
apparently are actually
eight without any distinction or
representation of the legion
here in the gerudo desert of all places
is why we feel there is another
explanation for the status mysteries
very well said sir it's clear that using
the seven
sages of yore to explain the eight
statues isn't the most
neatly fitting option so let's talk
about what might be
instead what if the eight statues don't
represent the sages
but rather the eight races of hyrule
wait are there really eight races in the
land of hyrule
there are you have the hylians the chica
the gorons the rito
the zora the gerudo the forest dwellers
also known as koroks also known as
kokori and the allegedly extinct ancient
barbarian race known as
the zonai that's right this video is
also kind of a zonai theory
if you came here from commonwealth
realms video though i guess you already
knew that
but back to the races of hyrule as you
can see there are seven statues with one
removed from the others
and in hyrule there are seven races of
hyruleans with one removed from the
others interesting isn't it
but the proof for this is more than just
numbers and somewhat vague similarities
you see even though we previously stated
that these statues don't possess
any unique identifying traits that was
only somewhat true
there are actually two very unique
identifying traits that all of the
statues share
the first being their oddly specific
powers that they're each said to
represent
skill spirit endurance knowledge flight
motion and gentleness the second unique
trait being the unique symbols that they
each have somewhere on their surface
except for the removed statue the eighth
these seven symbols are used in a kind
of matching game with corresponding orbs
to make a shrine appear but what if they
were more than just
random symbols i mean nintendo is very
specific when it comes to symbology in
zelda games
they've used symbols since the original
games to represent ideas
artifacts or even people groups i think
it's fair to assume that the seven
symbols represent the seven
powers spoken of by the gerudo legend
but let's take that
one step further and try to test this
racial symbology by matching the powers
and corresponding symbols to the
hyrulean races
actually i've already matched the powers
and races together and i'm just going to
skip explaining all of that for the sake
of time
let's start with what is far and away
the most compelling and obvious piece of
evidence for
all of this symbology the gentleness
symbol or in my opinion
the symbol of the koroks you see this
symbol is actually an
exact representation of the classic
kokiri symbol seen in ocarina of time
and as mentioned before
the modern day koroks and ancient kokori
are actually the same race of forest
dwellers
not only is it already very similar in
shape to the symbols seen on the kokori
shield but
if you add in the emerald portion to the
kokori emblem
it literally becomes the same symbol the
others are admittedly not quite as
obvious as this one but with the
specific attention to detail that the
zelda developers have for symbology in
this very game
the forest dweller gentleness symbol
seems to be undeniable
the other symbols are a bit more
debatable as they're all unique to this
game
but we'll try to place them with the
most likely options
the gorons represented by endurance are
most likely the symbol here that
resembles an
upward pointed arrow this could be a
reference to a mountain or more
specifically death mountain which the
corons famously
live on the sheikah represented by
knowledge are most likely this symbol
which resembles an open
eye similar to the other more well-known
symbol the rito represented by flight
are most likely the symbol which
resembles a sleeker upward arrow
referencing to the sky the zora
represented by motion
are most likely this symbol that
resembles a wave or stream of water the
gerudo represented by skill
are most likely this simple here that is
just two dots
one on top of the other this is one of
the more vague symbols but we have
decided it's most likely the gerudo due
to the process of elimination
and the use of evenly spaced dots which
are at least somewhat similar to the
other more well-known
symbol finally the hylians represented
by spirit
are most likely this symbol that closely
resembles a real-life
horse site this is of course due to the
process of elimination but could also be
a representation of the equal
or even statues that hylians share with
all the other races of hyrule
they are like the glue that holds them
all together the symbols may all be
unique to these statues
since they were created by the ancient
gerudo who probably came up with their
own symbols to represent the other races
why they got the forest dweller symbol
down accurately however is yet to be
determined
then there is the matter of the eighth
statue the forgotten one
that has no representation of power or
symbol
while the zone i famously have a swirl
as their alleged symbol
this isn't necessarily proven to be
accurate in the game and the fact that
they have no symbols or powers
associated with the statue
is actually in line with the status of
being forgotten or we know
they could have gone extinct before even
the statues were created
as with many things in breath of the
wild this is still pretty vague stuff
but given all the similarities and
evidence and symbology we just talked
about
this seems to be the most likely
solution to the age-old mystery of the
heroin statues but what do you guys
think
are they the gerudos ancient
representations of the eight races of
hyrule
or somehow still representations of the
sages or something else entirely let me
know in the comments below
also huge thanks to conrad from the
commonwealth realm for helping out with
this theory and being the person behind
the idea in the first place
and huge thanks to you for watching if
you enjoyed it please consider dropping
a like below to get this spread around
on youtube as that is literally how it
works on this platform and subscribe if
you haven't already to stick around for
more theories and nintendo content just
like this
also humongous thanks to my supporters
who make my day
every day say hello to claire e
melmellow
and connor h who have all joined my
elite bandit crew
if you're interested in doing the same
and helping make the next video come to
life and also maybe help put some food
on my table
click that join button located below or
follow the links in the description to
my patreon page
also down there are the links to my
social media pages so come on over and
say hi on twitter
it's free oh also happy valentine's day
at some point today do yourself a favor
and check out my valentine's day special
where i read your zelda pickup lines
it's it's something alright anyway
that's all i've got
this is masentana bennett signing out
have a great rest of your day
peace
[Music]